[Musique]
cherry notre camille combal nous a
laissé ce qui sera de retour demain
kameni c'est un petit peu malade mais il
nous a laissé un camille dans la rue
très très drôle
regardez ce qu'il a fait c'est encore du
grand grand camille combal c'est parti
oui salut tout le monde
c'est camille combal l'intermittent
j'espère que ça va je suis désolé je
peux pas être là ce soir je suis très
très très malade j'ai sors de chez le
médecin
j'ai une rhinopharyngite virale ça
s'invente pas je peux gérer notre pas
que ça existe donc je suis chez moi ça
c'est mes chaussons et ont fait pas plus
dégueulasse ça c'est mon chat vraiment
un fond devant l'émission et je tiens à
vous dire
déjà je serai là demain et pour ce soir
je vous ai réservé plein de petits trucs
des petites choses à déguster des
[ __ ] de petites images des choses
comme ça et je voudrais que ce soit le
meilleur de tout ce qui les lance su
pour moi et le est le plus doué qui
vraiment à du rythme et qui va vraiment
de faire briller cette chronique c'est
mathieu de l'ordre non je déconne c'est
maxime gay ni bien sûr maxime allais
donne tour et moi je suis de retour
demain je vous embrasse
bisous tu me passes et un maul
aujourd'hui on va piéger des gens avec
une corde à sauter le principe est très
simple il faut une corde à sauter et un
clément la crise ça tombe bien j'ai les
deux sous la main caroline je sais faire
de la corde à sauter copies wii on fait
d'abord de la corde à sauter normal on
va tester être sûr que la tête du tiers
ensuite on demande les yeux si tu tiens
30 secondes en faisant de la corde à
sauter tu gagnes un ipad nador attention
on y va on essaie déjà comme ça
attention et
[Musique]
avec une casquette avec sa jeune homme
ne triche pas je te sens tricheurs non
non ouais 0e et a été bon poursuis ta
gueule
je
[Musique]
ils sont une blague n'était jamais
encaissé de but est la meilleure au
service
[Musique]